the house votes to impeach president
trump for a second time
the debate over big tech censorship it's
heating up again
youtube now the latest company to ban
president trump from its platform
the company suspending the president's
account for the next seven days
quote after review and in light of
concerns about the ongoing potential for
violence
we remove new content uploaded to donald
j trump's channel
for violating our policies end quote
and some news of the so-called
conservative some news about the new the
so-called conservative twitter
platform parlor the ceo now saying his
social media app may not return
at all after being shut down
uh dana perino amazon responded
in a you know in in the court today they
they had a
suit response and they said that parlor
really was the banning them was about
violent content they listed
100 100 plus examples of violent content
things like
we are going to fight for a civil war
white people need to rain down
suffering and death death threats to
mitch mcconnell barack obama and others
do you agree that's violent content
well um look i don't like it when it's
aimed at me
and i think that everybody here has has
things like that that are aimed at them
online and it can be
completely disturbing um it can make you
lose sleep at night
it can make you want to get off these
pro the platforms
all together um and i'm not obviously
i'm not for it
i don't think anybody is for it i am for
speech and
free speech and speech is not violence
but can the again the fbi is
monitoring some of these things like for
the riot and they're like yeah well we
picked up on it and they said that they
were going to be there like it's one
thing to make
a threat that's general but when it gets
specific there are problems
and i think that in the wake of the riot
when amazon was looking at
its terms of service and then parlor's
terms of service
and they just decided to shut it all
down i don't know how the lawsuit
will turn out i i think that parlor has
some pretty good lawyers
but i mean amazon has got great lawyers
and remember
youtube that you mentioned the parent
company company is google
i think that within the first six months
of this year you are going to see
a pretty concerted effort and i think it
will be bipartisan for different reasons
but for regulation of the internet
companies biden watson
the republicans want it there will be
something that happens in the next six
months
katie the the the platforms again are
making the case that this is not about
censoring people left or right but
about violence i wonder if it's
persuasive to you that they
acted only after the events of last week
yeah it's actually not persuasive at all
if the standard in the terms of service
for these companies is that you can't
post
violent content then that's fine but
they need to do a better job of policing
it equally you know facebook was sued a
number of years ago
by an israeli attorney for uh hamas and
other terrorists there
posting on facebook about how they were
going to go out and commit terrorist
attacks and then they actually did it
and killed people and facebook tried to
wash their hands of it and say that they
weren't responsible
there's plenty of violent rhetoric that
goes on on the internet but this idea
that it doesn't happen on twitter
that doesn't happen on facebook that it
only happens on somewhat conservative
websites
especially parlor isn't true now can
they do a better job of policing it
sure but this idea that it's only coming
from from one website
is just beyond parity actually
uh jesse do you think though that these
private companies
that's what these platforms are uh our
right to regulate what they see is
violent content
well if speech is violence and silence
is violence
then what am i supposed to do one i mean
seriously there's no way out
but if you read what youtube actually
wrote in their statement it's pretty
scary they say they have concerns
for the potential of violence just take
trump out of it for a second you have an
unelected wealthy liberal executive
probably living in california
deciding on his own or her own
what he or she feels might cause the
potential
for violence think about how low that
standard is right there
are nra videos gonna get nuked next
are ice videos you know they said
abolish ice
i mean could the videos from the five
get nuked dan is constantly
tossing around reckless rhetoric that
could incite violence at any moment
i went on youtube today juan and i i
typed in
nwaf the police remember that video
that's on there yeah that that could
incite a potential for violence
madonna i want to bomb the white house
that's on there
snoop dogg putting a gun to trump heads
that's on there you got antifa videos
you got jihadi videos
i mean what don't you have on youtube
the problem is the left
only sees the potential for violence on
the right
so what they do is they have these
little squirrels at cnn that call these
corporations and say hey guys
and they start harassing the
corporations what are you going to do
about this what are you going to do
about that guy we're going to do about
that guy
until these corporations are like fine
leave me alone we'll ban them
and then you can't have a competing
platform because they're monopolies
and they'll just take you out like they
did parlor
all right so pete what i'm thinking is
if this was
democrats or leftists you just heard
what jesse said
and that kind of language don't you or
even if it was terrorists foreign
terrorists al qaeda isis
don't you think we'd want american
companies to protect america
yeah wouldn't you think uh the the
leader of the leading state sponsor of
terrorism in the world
uh the ayatollah of iran has a twitter
account and tweets all the time about
the destruction of israel
and death to america yet twitter the
american company
does nothing about it when it comes the
day the parlor was banned juan
what was trending on twitter hang mike
pence trending
uh and so they of course they
selectively uh
went after parlor as an alternative to
them where there's real free speech what
happened here one is your favorite word
collusion okay this is collusion of big
tech companies
going against trump supporters and
people advocates of free speech because
they control it it's very orwellian you
don't need just the government to have
authoritarianism
you can have corporations uh the media
collude together
to push people out of the public square
that they don't like and that's
precisely what's happening and
as far as parlor is concerned they may
never come back they literally have no
servers and may never come back
this is the unpersoning of george orwell
and it's the left that's doing it juan
wow that yeah okay